oder willst mich verarschen mich auch
schon die ganze zeit galt laut blöcke ab
und ersetzt sie wieder
so und da sind wir zurück in der today
show hallöchen zusammen mit den un in
seenot ob halo reach expo aber papa papa
krone ungefähr seien nicht vom alter im
gegensatz zu zum zum netter sind die
mobs echt geil
dadurch bin ich brauche noch ein paar
worte halten aber richtig knapp ich
drehe mich um gelesen krieg hinter mir
ich darf nicht sterben ich viele bräute
noch immer noch ein oder zwei mops dann
bin ich dann bin ich dann hier sieht
aber geil aus senden denn schlaf zu
erforschen so hinter deinem haus gebaut
was bauen da wo du die regelt ist so
dass den abegg dann wäre da auch ein
junge an der wand ich habe bei mir sind
diese komische in minecraft familie
nicht schön wenn level 15 jetzt hier ein
crafting menschen den kisten der luft
boah creeper überall louis irgendwie
ziemlich riskant hier alles was ich hier
machen wir wollen
was hast du kaputtgemacht nicht heraus
repariere reparieren was denn was ist
denn genau gesehen
du bist ja schon bald nur noch eine
treppe gebaut sei stolz auf mich eine
tolle und landen und dann das oder oben
kommt dein haus drauf da hinten keine
ahnung ich weiß gar nicht was machen
soll was ich sage mal ganz so schöne
sachen wie so viele hier so ein paar
glas sache nicht wer fast runtergefallen
in die schlucht und wer tot gewesen
30 leveln durchdacht richtig wieso fällt
in der glas hat das jemand weg gemacht
also ich gelaufen bin war das noch alles
da machst du irgendwie alles kaputt ist
das glas damit gemacht
ich habe bei mir echt so wenig sortieren
will ja ich habe eine kiste diaz oder
drei kisten sind sortiert und dann noch
zwei krims krams kisten einfach alles
drin und die sind dann voll da muss man
sich eine neue krimskrams christ habe
ich jetzt noch etwas was ich hier
beraten muss ich muss ich das glas neues
machen weil nur noch das weg gemacht hat
wer sonst so lang ist hier noch nicht
geschluckt haben wir als letztes mal
entdeckt mit ticketings ging ich glaube
ich jetzt in einer höhle ich weiß wenn
ich mach ja ich wollte noch was bei dem
was soll ich bauen was soll ich bauen
frage ich glaube ich mein haus ein
bisschen anders
na ja ich wollte mein haus ab ja ich
verändere oft sachen in meinem haus
allgemein muss das ganze hier mal ein
bisschen schöner machen
mit gesten ganz viel und schon folgt das
nächste thema david haye beiträge wofür
sie verwendet werden steht da ein
kommentar und ich denke mal was sonst
noch dazu gehört immer dazu
die daten hat ihr haus allzu
haushaltsabgabe gez mit abgeschafft so
zu sagen und dass stattdessen mit die
haushaltsabgabe
das heißt jeder haushalt muss zahlen
unabhängig davon ob ein radio überhaupt
hat oder einen fernseher fernseher
überhaupt hat und das sind ja nicht ganz
unerhebliche ausgaben von fast 20 euro
im monat knapp 20 euro sind das glaube
ich
die man im monat zahlen muss jeder
haushalt hat ist gar nicht so wenig wenn
man sich mal überlegt als student von
wie 400 euro im monat lebst dann nur
direkt geht es 20 euro weg nur dafür nur
gez die man vielleicht nicht mal
wirklich schaut oder benutzt im internet
was also nun gehört also da sind am
anfang war es ja so dass der meinte in
der kommentar frage ja verdammt denn
verwendet den verteidiger vom also haben
sie selbst noch mitbekommen dass
anscheinend kathrin huber hat das dank
der kathrin huber gutes thema auf jeden
fall aber dass die dafür verwendet
werden was kann ich mit einer schere
glas abbauen
der glanz nachbauen die kann ich lasse
sich die last merkel zog bekommen habe
ich nicht mit einer spitzhacke essig
touch glas kaputt aber kein sand macht
man mit zig touch dann kannst du
ich bin jetzt abbauen kann das
funktioniert nicht
jedenfalls habe ich jetzt ist doch davon
gehört dass die idee dass von den gez
beziehen wir sowas eines vorteils sehen
was kann auf einem rang eins gehört dass
davon jetzt wohl die öffentlich
rechtlichen fernsehsender in die geld
abbekommen für neue serien und so weiter
und so fort und daher wird nun außerdem
auch das programm die super nanny von
rtl auf swr glaube ich verlagert und da
gab es auch einen skandal sei legal
zum skandal beim swr und zwar haben sie
dort an den trailer hochgeladen von der
super nanny auf swr auf youtube und da
waren wirklich ungefähr 70 prozent der
kommentare waren gegen sie und die haben
echt kommentare einfach gelöscht also
scheiß auf freie meinungsäusserung
einfach kommentare gelöscht
und da hat sich dann einer darüber
geäußert auch hier sieht man dass
kommentare gelöscht werden da meinte der
swr über den offiziellen youtube-kanal
zurücklässt ist doch quatsch ganz im
ernst
und sowas find ich echt kacke 30 werden
dich dürfte zwar gerade events vom thema
ab aber muss mal gesagt werden
denn wenn die beim swr wenig vor wie man
mit youtube umgeht und da oder löschen
und jeden fall das ist die andere
bemerken da natürlich noch und dann
sagen hier wäre ein kommentar gelöscht
man klickt auf kommentar anzeigen da
steht dieser kommentar ist nicht mehr
vorhanden weil er gelöscht wurde
und dann sagen die noch nicht ganz im
ernst ist doch quatsch und wenn sie dann
bei einem anderen video wurden jetzt
allgemein die bewertungen deaktiviert
und kommentare wie schon sehr abwegig
vor allem salz öffentlich rechtlicher
sender aber dass die öffentlich
rechtlichen sender die gez beiträge
womit das ja angeschnitten hast du die
werden natürlich für neue serien und für
alte serien für alles verwendet das sind
ja die haupteinnahmequellen vor
wir dürfen ja kaum werbung ganz
festgelegten salsa anders als pirat
fernsehen aber das ding ist halt dass
man hat sozusagen das ist ja wie eine
steuer ist die muss jeder bezahlen egal
ob er will oder nicht
und es sei denn man kann ich sehen und
kann ich hören dann ist man glaube ich
davon befreit
du willst mich verarschen nein ich fühle
mich auch schon die ganze zeit galt
blöcke ab und er setzt sich dahin sehr
witzig und und dass davon halt so was
wie die super nanny finanziert wird und
ob das wirklich nötig ist bei sowas kann
man sich im zweifel auch privat sender
anschauen und das öffentlich rechtliche
fernsehen sollte vielleicht 5 euro monat
höchstens und dafür dann wirklich nur
wichtige sachen wie die tagesschau oder
so was halt unabhängige medien hat was
wäre eigentlich auftrag der
öffentlich-rechtlichen medien ist und
nicht so ein unterhaltungsprogramm war
das kann ja auch auf dem privaten
sendern sehen oder findet ihr es gut
dass wir da 20 euro im monat zahlen und
dafür bekommen wir die bundesliga
zumindest um zumindest die sportschau
und die wm live und so was alles wie
seht ihr das
die muss nämlich auch zahlen zumindest
wenn du irgendwann seine guckst du nicht
du musst es bald so oder so zahlen
ich schaue mich auch gar kein fernsehen
warum nur fernsehen wenn wirklich so was
läuft was mich auch interessiert und
dass es in letzter zeit so gar nicht der
fall das einzige kuckes fußball fußball
habe ich jetzt wurden mittlerweile auch
schon liga total über das internet
vermehrt angucken und aus dem fernsehen
wieder stück weniger oder sowas wie
super bowl das gucke ich mir dann weg
das ist die einzige zeit durch dann kann
man so viele stunden am stück
ist das eigentlich nie gesehen dass in
der schweiz der schweiz weise in
österreich ist glaube ich so dass der
öffentlich-rechtliche rundfunk dort ist
so organisiert dass man dann is marked
card bekommt das ist so ein decoder
sozusagen also das ist wie die premiere
oder wie sky als dann nur die leute die
halt die gez dort bezahlen die bekommen
dann so eine karte und können sich dann
das programm angucken sonst bekommt man
das nicht zumindest glaub ich das
ungefähr so funktioniert da könnt ihr
die österreicher und nein oder brause
die nicht eigentlich muss ich dazu sagen
nur die die zahlen das wirklich bekommen
und jeder nicht zahlt dem es scheissegal
was im fernsehen läuft getrieben wie und
wie oft da was gezeigt wird dass dies
dann einfach nicht richtig den ersten
applaus von mir jetzt gesagt wenn du was
haben willst du doch dann kommst du hier
hin
und ja und dann fragst du wieder sonst
weiß ja nie was du alles einfach weg
nimmt ich weiß auch nicht was wir alles
nimmt die frage wie ein kleinkind muss
man erst fragen steht 30 nur gucken
nicht anfassen sagt wolf an der
bitburger werbung im kinderhaus von
meiner mama geklaut nein dann hat es von
da geklaut jonas folger chris i
ich muss ein bisschen pvp eigentlich
will er wieder in meiner haut muss auch
wieder reinkommen das endet so gemacht
aber ich dachte ich wieder voll durch
mit unbedingt noch alle kalkar juni also
die letzten zweifel gehen ein
schlafzimmer das ist da unten jetzt zuge
mauer
ich begreife ich kannst du zehn
milliarden prozent schwören dass ich
ungefähr seit zehn folgen nicht mehr da
unten war ja das war nur dort glaubt nur
laufender schwarz weiterhin draußen auch
via kabel so eurem in der wird er sagen
ich bin noch nicht fertig mit meinem
haus werde ich auch nicht hast du dein
haus abgebaut ist das haus weg das hat
nur noch abgebaut
die steine was ist erst abgebaut
könig zugetraut
wir wissen schon wieder dein haus
abgebaut von der regional lag das jetzt
auch so hässlich das war keine regionale
regionalexpress abstieg schon
regionalexpress nein ich bin der
kommissar geiles ich habe wieder was
gedacht bei ja nur aus nessa warzen
baust interessiert
die gäste immer wenn der gast gebäude
auch mein haus war lohan hat jetzt schon
thema wirklich schon durch wieder ach ja
wird nicht die gez
ich sag wieder ausführlich irgendwas
dann ja was für thema ich habe daraus
für dich was gesagt wurde ausführlich
was gesagt ja ganz lange was erzählen er
steht in kommentare lena sagt wieder
alles möglich hier dazu und ihr sagt
immer nur spaß
also ich würde eigentlich nicht so
regeln so wie sie zurzeit rege weil man
merkt richtig dass deutschland den
leuten das geld aus
daneben will und wenn die da meinen jahr
hat das nicht nur geld weg ganz mainz
oder scheiß egal ob ihr einen fernseher
oder ein radio oder irgendwas was noch
so irgendein strom angeschlossen ist
hier müsst geld geld dann an uns
bezahlen und davon geben euch dann so
richtig geile programme wie zum beispiel
spanier aus als auf swr was eh kein
schwein sehen will und ich würde mal
sagen dass die bürger da mehr mitsprache
richtigen bzw ich hätte mein brötchen ja
und für unterhaltung endlich finden
unterhaltung mussten nicht auf
öffentlich rechtlichen sendern laufen
früher gabs da keine privaten sender
also vor 30 jahren oder wann er ich hab
rtl war der erste private sender
du kannst deinen speck packen konnten
ich habe einfach gemacht und da gab's
halt soll damit fernsehen unterhaltung
muss das natürlich auch den öffentlich
rechtlichen seien aber jetzt ist da die
da notwendigkeit jahr nicht mehr gegeben
und darum würde es komplett reichen wenn
wir fünf euro bezahlen dafür gebe es nur
noch informationssendungen vielleicht
auch noch so reportage meine so
wissenschaftlich mal sein dass entweder
kann ich sein opa passt ja das ist das
muss gar nicht das gleiche schlechte
augen co kg weiter weg vom fernseher und
bekommst du quadratischer augen hate war
schon voll eckige augen vom so lange vom
fernseher rumsitzen luca stimmt kann ich
damit nicht mal von spiegel gelaufen und
haben geguckt wer das damals habe ich
das vertrauen in meine mutter verloren
nie wieder erlangt ich habe gar keine
eckigen wollen wir schlafen oder so er
war schluss machen
den abschluss machen ich mach schluss
sorry aber schluss 14 minuten eher heute
ein bus machen per sms ist billig oder
als web app ist kostenlos
wortwitz wegen internet unsere schon
wieder eine folge oder wie oder was
jetzt innerhalb minuten bei wieviel
minuten
jetzt enthalten in der nächsten folge
war ich mir schon denken und dann
verzaubert was was du hast noch danach
jetzt verfolgen so viel dass auch du
willst solltest du nichts
anspruchsvolles bauen oder das schaffst
du schon vielen dank fürs duschen
parteien bis zum nächsten mal macht's
gut